hartley pool the location for the fast
political clash since the general
election
the by-election here tomorrow part of a
wave of local and mayoral elections
across the country and labour's first
chance to prove
they can put a dent in the conservatives
electoral success
times it's going well keep going keep
going don't stop
but a chance to for boris johnson who
hopes victories in places like the west
midlands
will give him an easier ride into the
next election cycle
it's a very tough set of elections and
i think that when the conservatives when
we stood last time
for many of these council seats we were
at a particularly high watermark
i will be fighting for absolutely
everybody i would urge everybody
uh in the country get out and vote
labour with so
much to win well you're not gonna be too
disappointed
but plenty to lose two we've got to
rebuild into the next general election
that's the task in hand
this is the first test and we go into
that test fighting for
every vote but i never thought that we
would
climb the mountain we have to climb in
just one year
it's going to take longer than that
these local and mayoral elections matter
not more so than here not just because
they decide who run our public services
or our city regions
but because they'll give us the first
real insight
into whether the redrawing of the
political map in 2019
was a brexit blip or something more
profound
poland suggests that the political tide
is still
against labor with all the questions
that raises
for a leader elected to build back the
red wall
boris johnson undoubtedly buoyed by the
vaccine rollout
these are difficult conditions for any
opposition
but labour's already on a long losing
streak
and kierstarma has to prove he can make
some headway
beth rigby sky news hartlepool